yeah welcome to this video on playing
Grand Master silly park here from
Argentina and we got a Coonskin but
declined with a six-hour 86 this is a
very very old line it's not it's not so
bad actually the idea is to add one
point take on c4 play be five so i need
to be a bit bit cautious i cannot i can
play Knight f3 but i need to be aware
that he's maybe just taking it I can
exchange but it's not clear that you
know I can go see six and Bishop b6 and
this is kind of position is some is
fairly solid for black the the a
six-pound is not done not a substantial
weakness of something how do i setup my
pieces here may be anticipating c5 if he
wants to go see if I if it's not
necessary he can uh-huh this I didn't
expect okay at least this means that
he's probably feared shattering and not
not playing with Bishop g4 anything who
came so I have a nice might only five
yeah this is a possible way to to
release some of the depression look like
Queen h5 maybe yeah let's activate
hmm this was stupid I can just take me
to now for and I don't have any
compensation my queen h5 was really a
really bad move but actually saw you
before but I thought oh well he won't do
that f of course evil yeah this is an
additional issue with Queenie three I
thought this isn't such a big problem
though it's not really it's not this is
not really threatening anything this is
the screen check I've got everything
covered here yeah the Queen on h4 covers
have to really look f3 is not winning or
what where do you go
where do you go on Luke see to brookey
30 days no mate I've got it covered so
I'm young Queen up funny enough how do
how to proceed though it's winning but
that it's a bit a bit tricky I think I
should should make sure that I don't get
made it on the back rank always an
embarrassing possibility so just night
g3 may be right at five coming why is
changing some stuff the check is not
really helping you I hope
I'm also threatening now night 97 with
the latest happen that's a good move now
I think with their this made on h7 let's
let's just look for a moment yeah it's
93 I can take f6 with a media
intermediate check and now this should
fall apart yeah this was lucky I didn't
even I mean I somehow saw the screen
before but I didn't really see the the
implications and now i just have night
a549 h5 meeting him it's no way to
prevent that night h5 is even even more
more forceful yeah now I can go here
Quincy 327
this is not made we are not not entirely
okay but that's a bunch of moves winning
rook g8 coming Queen f7 yeah yeah
understand us understand that is a bit
frustrated because I really played this
quite an erotic fashion me allowing this
queen before stuff yeah the overall
setup properly was wasn't great when you
can't play that what they're for but you
need to be probably a little bit better
um situated with the pieces guy now of
course this is ridiculous or maybe I
need to go Queen back now or so but this
this is just stupid now I've got these
two hanging and I'm not quite sure what
i thought okay i know he went here yeah
this is probably already a mistake
because it's not doing much probably it
didn't realize that i got it all covered
and the Queen covers afterwards it's a
Quincy coincidence I didn't plan
anything of that he can he can take him
and it's just a pawn I mean I can now
okay i can i can try something like this
but okay black as 1 upon i'm a bit
active at the moment but it's it's not
enough for me yeah yeah but this now is
this a bit bitter bitter a bit tricky
how does he do that in fact after here
there's queen d 3 this is actually quite
quite a case though oh this is how this
is a this is probably even though nice
for black he's very good he's very well
coordinated now and of course it's just
more material in the game it was just a
queen for look and now it's Queen them
again stroke and minor piece and my
minor pieces and my all my pieces are
not very well coordinated something like
this yeah I'd actually uh maybe black is
better even yeah there's some Justin
justice here in chess sometime so I'm
punished here for the for the somewhat
sloppy play with Queen age 5 and so on
yeah and in the game I thinking that it
was just it was just over it's just a
queen dial for work yeah but he was
terribly irritated i guess that suddenly
the Queen was so strapped but clearly
three is really am it's really still
quite good okay thanks for watching